yeah what took you so long man hey
youtubers is charlie so this is gonna be
like a janky audio only trailer
breakdown these are starting to get a
little weird at comic-con it's gonna be
crazy this next weekend but there's just
like so many big things that they
dropped during that Doctor Who panel
which I just posted in the trailer which
confirms a couple really big things that
they kind of leaked earlier this year
most notably Maisie Williams and the
premiere date it's going to be September
19th which is a little bit later than
last year like last year was August but
honestly I think that it's better that
they premiered in the fall it just feels
like not as many people watch television
in the summer months so the important
stuff first the first episode is called
The Magician's apprentice we've known
that for a while now the second episode
is the witch's familiar it's basically
it's like a two-part beginning there's
going to be a lot of two-parters this
season but not every episode is going to
be a two-parter it seemed like a lot of
people didn't like that they did so many
one-offs last season I feel like them
serializing it just like a little bit
more gives them some interesting story
telling opportunities it is easier to
tell a story when you have two hours
than it is when you have one Murray gold
is writing some new music he said he
wrote a song for one of the episodes
which makes you think of this guitar
that Capaldi's holding I don't think
that those are connected he just he said
that in the episode that he did the song
for people are singing in the background
who knows what the guitars for but
everyone prepare your mad max jokes like
Mad Max in a box with a flaming guitar
there is this really weird rock and roll
vibe that the doctor is giving off like
especially that that shot where he puts
his shades on and he's also wearing it
when he's playing with the guitar hear
the voice over that he has to ed's add
some really interesting context for
what's going on with the TARDIS like the
way they featured in the trailer but the
way they shoot it makes you seem like
something Crazy's goin on like the
TARDIS itself will be a villain at some
point this season every time I think it
can it surprises me it's evil I hate it
I want to kiss it all over it might have
been clear but I think he's talking
about the TARDIS as much affection as he
has for all of his companions including
Clara he loves the TARDIS most the
trailer juxtaposes that with a bunch of
other concepts most notably Missy they
talked a little bit about this at the
panel but Moffat said that you would not
be able to figure out how Missy
re-enters the doctors life is like a
completely unexpected way I don't
really know what that's supposed to mean
I'm sure of like the tens of millions of
fans there's like somebody is going to
guess exactly how Missy's going to come
back but her coming back is not the
surprise Moffat already said that the
master is an unkillable character so of
course Missy's going to be back Michelle
Gomez seemed like she was pretty
surprised though she's like I was really
happy to get the call but series 9 will
push deeper into the dynamic between the
doctor in the master and how the master
becoming Missy has changed that the
doctor loved the master I mean as a
friend before he ever knew about the
TARDIS so if the doctor loves the TARDIS
think about how he feels about the
master Capaldi said that it's one of
those situations whereby you see someone
enter a room and you're like oh this is
this is so wonderful but then you
suddenly realize that all these terrible
things are going to happen like he'll
feel happy to see Missy but then what
follows will give them the worst
headache ever he'll be like okay well
clearly something terrible is going to
happen now that she's back so think
about the way the TARDIS the master or
miss ER however you want to think about
her and the doctor are connected with
this speech that he has in the trailer
it's evil I want to kiss it all over
there'll be a couple new characters this
series but the Zygons will be back and
it has something to do with Osgood
Osgood is back but they didn't really
explain whether it's classic Osgood or
its Saigon Osgood that makes me think
that there's like a Saigon that thinks
it's Osgood and that might be the logic
that they use to bring her back I was
really happy to see some of these other
planets like they always have really
good cg of the planet shots even even
though they don't spend a ton of money
on Doctor Who a lot of people have
pointed out that this city here looks
like a city on Skaro a Dalek City from a
1963 episode even though Moffat does
like a lot of new things there there's
literally like nothing in Doctor Who
that is not inspired by classic ooh like
even if it's like a camisa billions for
instance probably a new character that's
inspired by someone from classic who but
if anything like this trailer just makes
series 9 look goddamn beautiful that's
where I feel like doctor who is a show
blows people away like it's been going
for so long but they work so hard at
making it look new every year that even
if you're not totally happy with the
direction the story goes the visuals
still blow your mind let's talk about
Maisie Williams though Capaldi said
something really funny
during the panel they were asking like
you know what would your character want
to go back and see like who do they want
to see most and Capaldi was like he
really wants to see his granddaughter
again which is Susan Foreman so like
that you know I know you want to draw
the connection in your mind but I feel
like he wasn't giving a spoiler away so
by transitive property I think that
Maisie Williams is not Susan they do
know each other but it doesn't look like
she's super happy to see him so like I
said I think she's just someone inspired
by classic ooh but she's still a new
character like someone that they can
bring back on the shelf like if Maisie
Williams ever wants to come back in the
future but let me know just looking at
the brief footage in this trailer how do
you feel going into series 9 compared to
series 8 I feel like series 8 had to do
the job of introducing this brand new
doctor so it was like only you know half
the people we're gonna hate it no matter
what I think they did an interesting job
but I think now the Capaldi has
established himself they can have a
little bit more fun with the character
really the first year any new doctor is
always fighting the old doctor just
because people are so used to them so
what's going to happen is is I've
recorded the Sherlock panel Moffat was
there they did like a special recording
they even released a trailer for the
Sherlock Christmas special which is
completely taking place in period the
way they explained it is is that it's
it's all the characters in the cast like
that isn't changing they're just asking
the question what would Sherlock look
like if it took place during the classic
setting the conan doyle setting so i'll
post the panel next it should be up by
early in the morning then after that if
I have time I'll post like a Sherlock
trailer video tomorrow's a really big
day though there's Walking Dead game of
thrones and Star Wars they're doing a
big star wars panel but there's not
going to be new footage they will be new
footage for walking dead though if you
want to follow me on Twitter and
Facebook I've been live tweeting the
panels and I also provide updates on
when videos are going to post so why you
guys wait for all that stuff to post you
can click this first link up here for my
master comic-con place it just has like
all the videos in it and you can click
here for the Doctor Who panel case you
haven't seen it yet thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
everybody let's high five just assume
that I'm high-fiving the screen right
now
you